regardez ça je vous en ai parlé c'est
l'odyssée art de samsung a laissé toutes
ses impressionnants l'espèce de petites
souris à droite on vient changer le
ratio et après on peut venir le tourner
c'est vraiment vraiment impressionnant
je vous montre la démo parce que truc
est dingue en plus vous avez des led de
côté donc ça c'est un truc qui est fou
c'est un prototype il est pas encore
sorti on sait par 2 sortira probablement
bientôt bien évidemment mais le truc est
un regard des premières utilisées comme
vous voulez pour du gaming pour ce que
vous voulez passionnément j'adore et
j'ai vraiment hâte que ça sorte et
pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas le mettre à
la maison dites moi ce que vous en
pensez parce que ma course a vraiment
dingue